GAVIN DOUGHTIE: I
am Gavin Doughtie.
I am an engineer on the
AdWords mobile team.
We're using Flutter.
And you're lying
about your state,
but I hope only to yourselves.
So since we're at a
cutting-edge tech conference,
I'm going to go all
the way back to 1981
and the introduction
of the Xerox Star
personal workstation.
Now, this computer is
famed in computer history
for introducing things
like the graphical user
interface and the mouse
and a bunch of other stuff
that Steve Jobs might have
seen once upon a time.
But it also included this, which
is the Smalltalk programming
language.
Now, this was actually one
of the major innovations
of this computer.
Smalltalk was a deeply
object-oriented language.
And it heavily influenced all
the languages that came after,
including Objective-C and Java.
And of course, Dart.
But one thing that it did that's
different from those languages
is it exposed an integrated
graphical user environment that
encouraged you to
think about the system
not as a bunch of
source code files,
but as a bunch of
live objects that you
could inspect and change
and add more classes to.
And not just the objects that
might be in your application,
but objects in the runtime
environment as well.
For example, the
CEO at the startup
where I was using Smalltalk
was not an engineer.
And when they saw the red
debugger window pop up,
she was like, oh,
these engineers
are not doing their jobs.
They shouldn't have bugs.
So we were able to change
the background color to blue.
[LAUGHTER]
So another thing
that Smalltalk did
was it promoted the idea
of a model view controller
architecture.
And we're not going
to go into this,
but I'm sure you guys
have read a lot about it.
And this was very
innovative at the time.
You could have things like
your model encapsulating logic
as well as the
data that operate--
as well as the data that
that logic operated on.
And it gave you a nice
separation of concerns.
But this was a while
ago, and the Xerox Star,
and many of the other computers
that came along afterwards,
were kind of designed
around the assumption
that you had a
single user sitting
at a single machine using
a single object model that
was sitting in memory and was
very sporadically updated.
It tended to be like slurp it
off disk, show it in memory,
and splat it back down at the
end when you saved your files.
And this model is really old
and not really relevant anymore.
So the way that data works
in your applications today
is more like this, where
you've got multiple users.
You've got multiple sensors.
You've got data being
updated in real time, right?
Or you have something like this,
where you have-- you might even
have the same user
using two devices,
like, oh, I'm going to do
some stuff on my phone,
and now I'm going to
jump over to my desktop
and make some edits.
And five other people doing the
same thing at the same time.
And the idea that I want
you to take away with you
is that of live data.
And really, I think
all data is live data.
All data is going
to change over time.
And it may not change
on the schedule
that you are thinking
about right now.
But we have tools for this now.
We also have this idea
of functional reactive
programming, where you
can think of things less
as I'm going to call functions
on an object and change that
object.
You can think of it
more as information
flowing through your
system, and you're
kind of like-- you're having
the components of your system
grab the data and look at it
and produce different data that
goes out the other end.
You can think of this
as data streaming around
in your application.
So Dart and Flutter make
it really easy to do this.
You've got a great Streams
API, the Dart Streams API.
It's full of rich operators.
If you want a formalism for
creating snapshots of data
as it changes,
you can use Redux.
Brian Egan's got a talk
about that tomorrow.
The next Lightning Talk
also is partly about Redux.
And if you want an even
richer set of operators,
you can use observables
with the Rx Dart library.
The author of that is
here at the conference.
And once you have
a stream of data,
you can use the
Flutter StreamBuilder
widget to render that data in
a pretty straightforward way.
I'm not going to go
over all the details,
but the main thing is
you can pass it a stream,
and the StreamBuilder
widget will
take snapshots of the data
coming out of that stream
periodically, whenever
the data changes,
and pass it to your
supplied build function.
So you can build
a widget from it.
So you don't have to like keep
state inside of your Stateful
widget.
You can just assume
that you're being
handed the next state that
your widget needs to render.
So don't lie to yourself.
The truth will set you free.
Oh, wait.
It's not.
I've got one slide.
OK.
Here's the real truth.
Smalltalk, even though
the user model was
you are operating
on objects, what
they were doing as you
made these changes is
they were writing these
changes down to a log file.
So you could take the base
image in this log file
and reconstitute your state.
So even if you go all
the way back to 1981,
there was still this
concept of a stream of data,
and the stream
was authoritative.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]